remember when nicholas cage had cgi abs
and played ghost rider before the mcu
even happened i remember that i saw that
movie twice on opening day because it
was the coolest [ __ ] ever when you're
only eight years old
now it's like
it's all right ghost with
how the hell do you make a thumbnail and
video title to get people to watch a
random review of the ps2 ghost rider
game which isn't relevant the slightest
i have no idea maybe if this was 2015 i
could have pulled it off but
this one's capping out at 45k and i'm
gonna have to live with that this review
was requested on my patreon by
pushanbattatria whose name i'm
terrified i'll mispronounce i i looked
it up and i'm like pretty sure i got it
pushing
pushing
if you would like to support me on
patreon it's only a dollar and that
would help me recoup the loss of time
money and sanity after this video fails
spectacularly like all my other uploads
lately
ghost rider is the story of a motorcycle
stunt man who makes the deal with saitan
to save the life of a loved one only for
it to blow up in his face blow off his
face and have his body possessed by a
guy named zarthos who i wish would have
a fight with these three characters
because flaming skeletons are sick
now johnny stunt bike and his flaming
bones fight evil at night and piss fire
in poorly marketed pseudo-sequels here's
a ps2 game about it based on that movie
they couldn't get the rights to nicholas
cage's face so instead johnny blaze
occasionally looks like uh
like james franco in this motion comic
art for the cutscenes
nothing spells quality in a video game
like cut scenes with emotion comic style
infamous gets a free pass the rest of
you are uninvited to my birthday party
this game's like a weird god of cry
devil may war mashup clone where ghost
rider whips demons with a chain with the
power of heck you got your strong
attacks and light attacks and
impractical spinning moves that look so
damn cool johnny b lazy swings his chain
like a ghost to sparta but he's also got
a hellfire shotgun like in the movie and
with a few big screen clearing attacks
he's a pretty tough guy i think this
game's satanic energy is too strong and
open a portal to hell that let the
demons into my ps3 controller because me
joystick started [ __ ] up something
fiercely then it just broke and now that
controller won't charge or turn on
anymore so i gotta use like the kind of
shitty broken other one and the new ones
i bought took three weeks to get her in
the mail combat's pretty fun
though it has the same button mashy
repetition problem that most character
action beat-em-ups like this suffer from
but you know what this game does a good
job mixing it up with the enemy
variations to keep you on your toes like
these irritating bat things that are a
lot faster or these guys that shoot
projectiles and of course big mini boss
monsters
and uh yeah you also get some nice
variation moves as you upgrade and it
doesn't take ridiculously long to afford
those upgrades oh yeah you know i'm
talking about this as if this is
something special and unique literally
every game like this is designed that
way or at least the competent ones
oh this game's competent
i like how you can upgrade your health
bar to be as long as a boss character
and take up a silly amount of the screen
that's always fun the enemies work in a
gameplay sense but their designs are all
just generic demons you could put these
guys in a spawn game or in the nether
realm levels of shaolin monks and they
wouldn't look out of place and either
they're just the same hell dwellers
you've seen a million times before i
feel like they could have pulled more
interesting demon designs from the books
to have something more badass and comic
booky but they seem to have reserved
that for the boss characters eventually
the enemy variation slows down about
midway through and it does start to feel
pretty tedious a cut scene will tell you
where you have to go next in the story
with some sense of urgency i have to
reach the church
but it'll take two hours of punching
monsters to get to that location and by
the time you get there you forgot why
you cared
the pace isn't going to use some work if
a video game tells me i need to get to a
location it either a needs to be the
main focus of the entire game with many
interesting sub areas along the way with
a reasonable justification for why it
takes so long to get there or b
i need to get there in 20 minutes
anything in between feels like busy work
the first boss of this game is ghost
rider's venom equivalent vengeance who
is a guy with the same powers and
costume as the hero but he's bulkier and
has a sharp monster mouth actually him
and venom hung out once you fight him as
well as the villain blackout in a race
sequence and neither of these are
particularly memorable i would have
preferred to fight them hand to hand
there's also lilith a demon lady who you
fight on the back of a peculiarly large
moving train
she's got another game coming out where
she's the main villain soon
card based no thank you sir and you also
fight scarecrow
the marvel one
the guy who um
has a surgical implant that gives him
pheromones that can trigger panic
attacks
in people close by to him
i guess they had to get dc back for the
aquaman namor thing eventually
actually they rip each other off all the
time they practically take turns
really come on the final boss of course
is blackheart except they don't push out
of showing his monster form like the
movies did oh hey this boss fight is one
of those
you know those it's one of those
i love those
in an ironic way i guess
[Music]
speaking of the racing segments they
didn't forget the rider part of ghost
man so there's these looping race tracks
where you have to kill the enemies to
progress or more linear ones where you
just have to get from point a to point b
without getting killed by these alien
racers the greatest enemy of ghost
rider's progress though is his own
nervous shakes where he'll occasionally
veer off a new wall and ragdoll worse
than nico bellic in the source engine
the races aren't boring or anything but
sometimes i found myself just trying to
ram into walls and obstacles at top
speed to see what the funniest possible
wipeout could be here's some highlights
of that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
god
damn
i mean in all fairness he doesn't have
any meat on his bones so he probably
would tumble like that after a huge
impact he's just like floating magic
bones connected by demonic hellfire he
doesn't have any cartilage he'd probably
float like that that's realistic this
game's story is sort of a non-entity
it's really short cut scenes spliced
into about four and a half hours of
gameplay that mildly explain where
you're going and what you're doing
basically mephisto is losing control of
his demons who are now rampaging on
earth and he asks ghost rider to help
rein them in which he reluctantly kind
of does because he was going to go after
them anyway so you know whatever might
as well this takes place after the movie
so a lot of the rogue demons running
around want to resurrect black heart by
stealing his body and doing some magic
on it after nicholas cage fried his
brain and then out of nowhere for no
real reason blade also shows up in the
story to help out this is [ __ ]
playing love holy [ __ ] he's playing
ice skating uphill that's unexpected and
weird and pretty cool i always like to
believe all pre-mcu marvel movies took
place in a shared universe together so
this sort of backs that up in a teeny
tiny way though blade doesn't help you
in gameplay he appears in cutscenes and
helps you save the world by killing the
demons who stole blackheart's body and
helping to hide it away
once you've beaten the game on new game
plus you can actually play as blade and
he's not a reskin either he's got his
own moveset and everything so you can
sort of pretend this is a blade game too
if you want just with unrelated
cutscenes about ghost rider eventually
the ghost writer finishes some really
monotonous demon slang and pending a few
pop songs that he'll make some nice
royalties off of only to find out that
mephisto the trickster satan has tricked
him delightfully devilish he wants the
demons to run rampant on earth and ghost
rider has been accidentally drawing a
giant glyph on the surface of the planet
with the path he's been driving all day
that'll create a hell portal
god that's pretty convenient mephisto
what if he like veered off the side to
go get like a burger or something or
maybe he needed to take a pee break
because we know he does that this plan
has some holes mephisto
much like most of your plans you
in spider-man ruining
face told everyone to read it i thought
it was really good it started strong
it was good for the first like little
bit and i was really excited that it
just kept getting
it's not my fault it turned out like
this it's not my fault i didn't do this
i didn't do this
i didn't do that and then blackheart
shows up alive and well even though he
was dead and blade hit him somewhere how
why when doesn't matter we needed a
final boss so don't ask questions idiot
then not nicholas cage and his weird
nicholas cage impression
you okay
i am
now what's that yeah mephisto is he gone
for now
take the girl and ghost right off into
the sunset
she's gonna jump his bones
he's a pretty hot guy
game's all right nothing spectacular but
it's not bad we'll call it slightly
above average was that positive enough
for you guys in the comments that always
go bro this game was my childhood how
could you diss on this in any review of
a game older than 2016
no
well [ __ ] off either way if you can find
a way to run a ps2 copy of this or the
psp version it's a simple but decent
game about ghost rider and since his
fans are starved for any kind of content
right now it might be a fun diversion
here's my contribution to hashtag spawn
timber now i know spawn isn't exactly
the same thing as ghost rider but
well let's be honest with ourselves
they're pretty similar
[Music]
[Music]
you